your intuition is very powerful for you
your gut check so you have this
intuition about this film which was
ruined me at that time to use me and
then you are several months into it
you're trying to write the screenplay
but you're struggling how was that for
you because you know yourself so well
that you know that you trust what you
feel what you're directed toward it was
terrible it was terrible it's just part
of the process you have to go down
detours and how do you get through that
I mean honestly you just grit your teeth
and keep going and try to believe in
that original inspiration that you had
because when you first get the idea for
a movie it's like super clear it's like
I don't want to say HD or 4k I'm gonna
say 8k clarity and then you have to turn
into a screen player then you have to
actually start filming it and then it
gets blurry like you know 1980s analog
TV and you're like where's my 8k clarity
it was so clear when I had the idea and
honestly that's just the process you
just have to commit to it except it's
gonna suck for a while and believe that
you're gonna come back to that original
peu idea that got you so excited I also
really believe you have to explore bad
ideas to get to the to get to the good
one so you need to reframe it as okay
you know what I went down a path that
just didn't work creatively great I'm
making progress I can put that aside
that's not what this film is gonna be
now that I know that I'm getting closer
to the ideas that are gonna work so a
lot of it is this kind of crazy sounding
positive self-talk but if I'm being
honest that's that's the kind of stuff
that keeps me going because it's hard
it's hard when it's not working you know
and pretty much give yourself time keep
pushing and have faith in that original
idea if it was strong enough to make you
feel something you know that there's
some nugget of gold and you just got to
get to it through perseverance well it
reminds me too of how you went to film
school after you'd made a movie or two
and and it's that's so interesting as
most people it's the opposite right and
and then they're either jaded or they
love it but you use it as inspiration
yeah I mean I mean look everyone's
different so I don't want to recommend
it
anything I'm sure but for me I needed to
go and make stuff on my own outside of
any system I needed to to take risks
fail succeed on my own find my own voice
I got to a point right just couldn't
keep doing that and I was burned out and
that was where film school came in and I
really studied okay what is Hollywood
screenwriting what is the hero's journey
you know all these really fundamental
things that was instrumental for me and
I've just made a movie that's kind of
edgy and and breaks the rules somewhat I
could break them because I learned all
the rules you know I know how to write a
three-act structure you know I did the
wonderful Michael Haig course I've seen
him on your shirt all that stuff is
brilliant and if you do want to make
like avant-garde edgy movies learn the
fundamentals of you know what you'd call
like Studio Hollywood storytelling learn
those beats inside out then you really
can break the rules one other thing I
will say film school is such a luxury
and I went into it with a funny attitude
I went into it like I want to make my
worst stuff here now I don't mean that I
set out to do an unprofessional job I
wanted it to be as good as it could be
but I pushed myself I made stuff that I
hadn't tried to make before because
there was a safety net I was at film
school if I made something truly
horrendous I could make it go away and
it would never see the light of day it's
not like it's gonna be a commercially
released film and my reputations on the
line so film school for me was great I
tried a bunch of different things I
realized there are certain things I kind
of suck at and I kind of found my voice
through that process so really I I had a
lot of failures at film school and
because I kind of got those out of my
system in a safe environment my work on
a lot better after I graduated and I
think that's why film school is actually
good for people it's not that they give
you some magic secret sauce you can
learn a lot online you can plug you can
learn a lot from watching film courage
truly you can you could probably learn
everything they could teach you but
there's something about that process and
failing in a safe environment figuring
out who you are just giving yourself a
year or two to walk on the tightrope
knowing there's a safety net there that
can be huge so that's why I would
encourage people to go to film school
give yourself that luxury to fail with a
safety net it really it's work for me I
mean it's great that there's all these
online classes and stuff but there's
really something about being around
other people even if it's just watching
what they're doing a hundred percent I
mean it's not just about what they teach
you it's the cohort you know and I have
collaborated with the directors who are
in my class you know I've acted a couple
times for Casey anning who's an
incredible Australian director who's
really going places
Stephen McCallum who just made his first
feature one percent
I think it's called outlaws in America
they become good friends and and
collaborators and you know they like
encouraged me to get back into acting
they were so adamant about and they cost
me as an actor and that really kind of
kick-started my acting career again and
then while I've been working on you know
directing and developing the script it's
like you know I went in did San Andreas
and got to work with Paul Giamatti I
went in did Portlandia I've been
shooting TV commercials in Portland so
it's kind of like I really credit film
school with leading me back to acting in
a funny way so yeah
you